hey daddy how many buddy dolls were on
too many - too many to count and like
yeah that was the whole thing it's like
I found myself constantly checking over
my shoulder or constantly staring at the
dolls to make sure that his head was
that way before
let's make sure it's still that way when
I like to look back but it was also kind
of like I know I'm a huge nerd like I'm
a horror movie nerd like I like I love
this stuff and so like to watch the
animatronics of it all like I was pretty
amazed that we buy 95 percent of his
movies like the actual doll and so why
it's like how its face could move and
like how it could a mode now we could
you know it was it was unlike anything
I've ever experienced I was wondering
that because I'm watching the movie I'm
like oh my god is that like yeah
happening on Saturday is it just yeah
yeah I can't imagine the body dolls on
set though I mean it's not like the
sexiest doll I've ever seen is it is
creepy as hell like he's really really
creepy and but at the end of the day you
know it was really interesting about
this movie is like I found myself caring
a lot for Chucky like I ended up really
really sympathizing with him like I
really want him to win like there are
moments I was kind of wiping tears away
because it was just like oh but I think
this is that's the testimony to my
camera as well like when he when his
voice was added he brings such this this
depth to Chucky and his compassion to
Chucky but then on if when the sinister
moment happens it's like you're
terrified like like even the way he says
peekaboo is really terrifying yeah but
you there's just I don't notice this
this Chucky is very different like I
just never thought that I would actually
care about Chucky you know it's so true
because you can feel that kind of like
et influence throughout them right yeah
influenced that way like it very really
really eased in and what I like about
this this version of chess play is a
send-up you know - those kind of those
kind of films like The Goonies them eat
see like because you watch like it's all
about like teaming up and like finding
real friendship like this movie is
really about friendship you know and
this interaction we have but also like
Chucky it has access to us like in any
like he's in the cloud he could control
anything he knows our lives better than
we know
and that's like that's terrifying but
that's the wave of what we're going
artificial-intelligence right like it's
intelligent it's learning this feeling
it's adapting and now Chucky's doing
that yeah I go home and I'm like Alexa
don't plug everything you're on yeah and
she starts talking anyway yeah where we
go if you really want to scare yourself
put your legs underneath your TV I put
it right where your TV is let's see what
happens because it lists listening to
everything you're watching and then like
it will literally like in the middle of
the night just start playing it's creepy
when you're talking about something and
then you go on your like Instagram and
then all this and there's an ad for it
you're like I know I said it all the
time I was all I wanted to do is see
where this box of cereal is and y'all
halt and keep getting the data but
that's weird that's weird it's weird um
I know that you are you mentioned you're
a huge nerd I know that because we
talked for spider-verse we talked at
Comic Cons and you were so excited so I
can't imagine how you're feeling about
doing the Joker movie with Joaquin
Phoenix it was it was it was very
interesting yeah he's like oh right like
because the more when you're a part of
these things you could have spent a lot
of time as the actor not being able to
talk about it so like as a nerd that's
like kryptonite like you want you I
bouncing anxiety or something I wanna
see something so bad but yeah which it
was really really really cool like
you've worked with two jokers right
Joaquin and Mark Hamill's yeah I know
and my hem was like the best voice of
Joker ever like so when I heard that he
was being Chucky I was like hands down
it's a no-brainer
[Music]